you know I never like people telling me  what I should do when I should do it to  me it was the most natural thing and I  was a kid to decide myself what I wanted  to do and how long  I think about time very differently out  here than people think about it down in  civilization  I don't think about how many hours I'm  gonna spend cutting with the Sun just  goes around the circle in the summer the  moon goes around the circle in the  winter those are the timekeepers out  here the change of the seasons that's my  calendar don't use a calendar don't use  a watch  and just tuned into natural cycles and  it feels a lot better  feels like time has expanded a summer  out here it's just like when I was a kid  knowing your little and summer just  stretches on for a long time that's the  way it is out here  once you D synchronize from all those  mechanized timepieces and rigid  calendars it's a whole different  sensation that goes on in your head  whole different experience at time